bill nighy oh here we go the new term
Bill Nye the anti science kind of a
religious zealot slash guy he came out
and he had some statements to make that
to me were about as scary as you can
think coming from someone who claims to
be a scientist or certainly as held out
as though he's carrying the torch for
modern science see if you can spot it
we've got an extraordinary situation
here in the United States where climate
change deniers have managed to introduce
the idea that some uncertainty say 2%
plus or minus 2% about the temperature
of the ocean is somehow equivalent to
plus or minus 100% now everybody science
is political we use politics to decide
where to invest our intellect and
treasure what what is it
we'll get to why that's incorrect and
why that's corrosive to the very fabric
of science in a second but this is also
a reason why people are tired of cable
news people in our generation because no
one on that panel they didn't have a
real scientist on that panel who could
just say exactly what everyone's
thinking it's somehow equivalent to plus
or minus 100% now everybody science is
political we use my politics that's it I
just want one person science is
political incorrect first let me draw
your attention to the definition of
science the intellectual and practical
activity and comes in the systematic
study of the structure and behavior of
the physical and natural world through
observation and experiment hmm
some would say that's the opposite of
politics some would say the purpose of
science is to exist in a prism
regardless of societal circumstance some
would say that's the main reason for
science it's kind of the through lunch
but you think he's right science he's
saying what we've been saying for a long
time and we've been excoriated for
saying that listen no one's saying there
isn't climate change but if you question
the idea that manmade climate change is
so catastrophic the government needs to
second step in your label to denier and
we've talked about how you need to get
in line
with the current scientific thinking if
you want the money science has become
political as far as where the funding
goes it's horrible if that's the case
but that is the case
case in point let's go to President
Barack Obama he openly said that he made
climate change a top priority now here's
an interesting note overall research and
development funding under Barack Obama
actually decreased but simultaneously
funding for climate change programs went
up so that means when overall funds were
going down for research and development
people who are studying climate change
in the way by the way that that stepped
in line with President Obama's narrative
made more money less what we've talked
about before we were so you're a
conspiracy theorist if say I want to
study I don't know the growing patterns
of cedar wood trees in the American
Southwest ah no grant denied I want to
study the growing patterns of cedar wood
trees in the American Southwest in
relation to climate change make it and
you see that in the numbers and here's
what's so alarming about this Bill Nye
what is he really saying bill might is
not like science bill nye doesn't want
science Bill Nye is pushing for a pseudo
scientific quasi intellectual religious
Oleg Archy I know you'll hear that on
YouTube because someone research through
an oligarchy but doesn't know what it
means what does that mean he means that
he only wants the people he only wants
people who agree with him to be in power
keep in mind this is a guy who by the
way is okay with jailing climate
sceptics okay feeling scared yet a
little bit that tingle in your nether
region that's fear that's fear for being
jailed because of your thought and
that's something that Bill Nye openly
supports let's get let's put aside if
you agree with his opinion or not he
wants people who agree with his opinion
exclusively to be in positions of power
and he wants those people in those
positions of power to be able to
determine where the finances are
directed do you have any idea how
anti-scientific and how terrifying that
is and if you want to know why that's
terrifying you can look to history as
far as the intermingling of politics and
science in the absolute Leviathan the
monstrous creation that it becomes it
can only merging politics and science
not allowing them to exist autonomously
of each other can only serve to alter
Sciences trajectory to the path of truth
okay that's the main purpose here and
Bill Nye wants that specifically some
examples I know it seems tired and old
hat but let's go to not
Germany that's kind of a prime example
of political science as it were with
their eugenics racism cloaked as pseudo
scientific sort of social Darwinism it
became a widely acknowledged that of
thoughts and it led to scientific trees
books research projects it also of
course led to gassing a few individuals
you're saying some scientists in Germany
we're all too happy to accept that
funding the funding was determined if
you believe in Sega Genesis your rights
are research paper and PubMed it's the
Jews Abed this happened if your science
was in line with not the Nazis in power
you got the funding you know if it
wasn't you didn't get the funding China
of course you have situations like China
Eastern Bloc countries liberal should
love this where homosexuality was still
declared nothing more than a mental
disease and it only has been dropped as
recently as the the mid 2000 in some of
these places let's get to Soviet Russia
genetic biology I don't want to bore you
with with too many details here but
under Stalin basically there was a
rejection of what we know to be genetic
biology in favor of a scientific
worldview as determined by the
government the Communist Party ordered
the rapid development of more productive
varieties of wheat and other important
crops again leftist should be thrilled
with this Soviet Russia basically
ordered GMOs but they ordered GMOs in a
way that flied in the face of biology
what we knew at that time and you were
excluded from the scientific community
unless you lined up with the
establishments belief the only reason
that this trajectory stopped why was
because there's science which was
political happened to be wrong and led
to fell crop failures and food shortages
so here's something to that really
concerns me we know it's unscientific we
know that the pitfalls here we're that
he's a bachelor's in mechanical
engineering so we know he's not a
scientist people but where are the other
scientists speaking up kind of like with
Islam where you know we say where the
Muslims speaking up against the acts of
terrorism not only against terrorism but
against Sharia law against the way
against women are allowed to worship in
mosques in the United States and equal
footing with men which so what are the
rest of the Muslims hashtag not all
Muslims what about hashtag not all
scientists shouldn't scientists people
who respect a scientific process be out
in droves
we're not Bill Nye why is a scientific
community not screaming in unison over
the hilltop
no we think that science should exist
outside of politics he's not one of us
seems because anyone who says that is
what excommunicated from the scientific
community for not thinking properly what
have we created we've created a
scientific community where not only is
groupthink encouraged depending on who's
in political power it's the only form of
thinking allowed by an elected treasurer
when it comes to from the full show
Daily Show at allotted with credit calm
slash mug Club or it's available
exclusively $69 a year that's less than
$6 a month less than two expensive cups
of coffee or you can feed an African
child but just buy coffee or join the
mug club Daily Show ladder with
credit.com slash mug Club see you there
don't feed children